c'est la journée les enfants les cherry
et donc on a on a on a fait appel
en fait aux mini mini chroniqueur nous
avons avec nos mini mathieu
applaudissements pour lui
tu t'appelles bonjour bonjour là bonjour
oui tu t'appelles matthieu delormeau
d'accord très bien ça va tu as fait quoi
hier soir ça rien fait car était content
d'être ici
oui et non c'est qui ton chroniqueurs
préférés à part toi jean luc jean luc
lemoine tamia l'on est loin de pouvoir
dans un instant ça serait bien que tu as
un scoop médiathèque quelque chose
aujourd'hui
oui vas-y à quoi bon soir tu te trouves
bon comme mathieu capsule avec à
comment ça va capucines tiens ça va bien
ma chérie tu es en forme avec le fils de
qui en ce moment il ya mini agathe qui
est avec le mieux adapté
[Musique]
et la ligne à gâteau poids les fameuses
comment ça vanne agathe moins ça va tu
es content d'être là oui pas fiancés
temps quelle classe non sans quelques
classes ppbe cpb danse et pkoi bipédie
d'été dans mes temps quelle classe
vraiment c'est pas seulement passer la
sepnb et au sabre lundi
[Applaudissements]
mais nick a pu l atout d'okapi sylla
on a nous le mini jean michel maire on
voit ça va mais les gens me bien j'avais
hâte à une meuf et non nantes a pas de
meuf
non tu as quel âge non on a 12 ans 11 11
ans tu m'as dit douce tout à l'heure tu
es aussi mito que jean-michel d'accord
en une minute il ma famille tall est
d'accord minutes chez les mollahs
[Musique]
ça va tirer oui comme en tant que classe
toi un style vif et mais quand on a vu
du petit rototo city est ce que tu as
une blague eh oui vas-y d'un fond de moi
ça dans mes 14 juillet le fonds de
brosses à dents le 14 juillet chez ba ba
adjoint fo dentifrice on a avec nous me
gilles verdez applaudissent aubry
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça a bien jeté yoplait l'échec comment
ça va bien
alors tu es content d'être là oui tu as
quel âge toi fais ta tête tout calme toi
mon chéri un oui dans quelle classe fait
pcp tu travailles bien cpb fait des ccp
ses doigts ouais mais agathe et aux
agathois gamme mini agathe et iag
acceptons ses pattes en cpcb thibout lui
dont cpc à cépie dit tu connais gilles
verdez oui comment il est en fait je
connais pas mimi zabel mans
comment savoir d'une isabelle ça va très
bien vous avez quel âge 15 ans quinze
ans ça va vous êtes donc de classe en
troisième troisième c'est c'est votre
vrai coiffure tout ça non pas d'accord
en tout cas ça vous va très bien les six
appels morini-bosc un petit peu on à
milan ac est avec nous écrivez nous
comment ça va miniers non mien est
content d'être là oui ça va tu aimes
bien la télé ouais tu regardes quoi la
télé imbert dessin animé ouais t'as quel
âge 7 ans mini jean luc est avec nous
[Musique]
sa maman lui les gens bien toi là tu
t'appelles ça me change dans exactement
ça va bien tu très élégant merci c'est
très beau si vraiment tu as quel âge de
12 ans 12 ans top class 6 5e 5e à 3
était encore en sixième
abbas était content tu connais jean luc
lemoine jean tu ne connais pas non tu
vas découvrir la corse ne l'a jamais vu
si tu as dit oui
[Applaudissements]
est ce que tu peux bien retirés
franchement il est valide si tu
t'appelles ça elle enfin certains cas
l'âge de 9 ans il est pas bon raphaël
agathe agathe tu te calmes il est pas
beau raphaël il est beau mais c'est 6
d'accord très bien d'accord dans ce cas
match laisse aussi cela les chéris
d'accord les merguez l'accord les
saucisses non ok il est ici